[Musique]
il y a au moins 5000 navires là devant
moi ce jour là ils fonce vers les
blockhauses de la plage de
colleville-sur-orne l'arme au point le
cœur serré chaque fois qu'il voit tomber
un camarade au total le bataillon perd
presque 25 % de ses effectifs Léon
Gauthier lui reste en Normandie jusqu'à
la fin des combats et pendant 78 jours
il est partout où les commandos se
battent en octobre 1944 il se marie avec
Dorothy Banks une Anglaise rencontrée
avant le débarquement et avec qui il a
deux enfants Jacqueline et Jeannette à
son retour en France il reprend des
études de droit pour devenir expert
automobile et ce n'est que dans les
années 1980 que Léon Gauthier commence à
accepter de raconter son histoire après
s'être installé à Ouistreham depuis avec
une grande humilité et non sans émotion
il continue de faire vivre la mémoire de
ses frères d'armes la guerre est une
abomination je l'ai faite parce que je
n'avais pas d'autre choix il fallait
qu'elle s'arrête et nous n'avons
combattu que dans ce seul but il n'y a
pas de héros mais des hommes et des
femmes plus courageux que d'autres quand
tout s'effondre